-Hey, everybody, we are back
with Cameron Diaz
here to celebrate Cameron's wine
brand Avaline.
She and I are going to face off
in the world's first ever
wine scooter race.
-We've done this before.
-Are you ready for this?
-I'm ready for this.
-Alright.
Now here's the way
it's going to work,
We're gonna be riding these
one-of-a-kind grape scooters
whiel wearing these wine
helmets, okay.
Cameron and I will --
-Are these grapes?
I'm so glad because right now
I've seen childbirth
and this looks like a different
situation.
-What is --
-Women do you know
what I'm talking about?
-Beautiful grapes.
These are beautiful grapes.
-They are grapes.
Cameron and I will race out of
these doors past our
roller skating cocktail waiter
and then we're going to
head to the elevator bend and go
around the wine mime.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Why does he get an applause?
Oh, you dropped it.
-He's juggling breadsticks.
-Then we're going to go back
down the hallway and pass a
bachelorette party
who's been rose-ing all day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
After that, we'll be careful to
avoid our 7-foot-tall
wine bottle --
-Holy!
-take a right through
the low hanging grapes.
and for the last leg of the race
we'll head through cork alley.
Where it looks like Hasthtag the
panda and the t-shirt Yeti are
having a cork fight.
Now, the first person to cross
through the boxes of wine wins.
And that's where we'll celebrate
with some
delicious Avaline wine.
Cameron, are you ready for this?
-I'm so ready.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Don't forget your brake.
-Yeah, don't forget the brakes.
-Jimmy hates to lose.
-Jimmy doesn't use brakes.
-He doesn't like it.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready?
-Yeah.
I thought you were in a speedo
and a bikini.
-What's that? No, that was just
my off-camera --
-Oh, yeah, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-Three, two, one, go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You cut me off!
♪♪
-Oh, my -- sorry, sorry!
-The other way!
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry! Did I make you drop your
wine, mime?
♪♪
-Wait, are we supposed to --
-Oh, my God!
Whoo!
-Wait, are we supposed to --
-[ Screaming ]
-Oh my God.
-Whoo!
-[ Screaming ]
-[ Laughter ]
-I lost my hat!
-Be careful!
Don't hit her.
-Ready?
-Yes.
Go for it, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
-We got to the finish
line together!
My thanks to Cameron Diaz.
Avaline is available now.
Thanks, higgins.
At drinkavaline.com.
Matt Smith joins us
after the
break.
Stick around, everybody!